lady why am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
our goal from day one is to make this
movie a continuation of the story for
woody and to expand the world at the
same time it's a interesting line to
walk for a sequel you want people give
people what they are familiar with and
what they love Jesse but not in the same
way so that's what we've done here is
just a show there's a continuation of
Woody's story but it's a different way
that he didn't even see coming you need
help with that no no I got it we always
want the audience to connect for these
characters and I think seeing our world
from the toys point of view is something
that's so unique to Toy Story there's
thousands of objects so I think in an
IMAX screen you're seeing this larger
scope in the art department we kind of
start from scratch so we literally have
a blank piece of paper and it starts
with research and then drawing so story
has already kind of come up with what is
going to happen and it's our job to
design and figure out what this place is
going to look like
[Music]
there's an unbelievable amount of detail
that you're gonna be able to see on an
IMAX screen in this movie in terms of
animation it was really important to to
remember how big they were for instance
you know Bo Peep is 10 inches tall and
so her movements would be a lot quicker
than say URI like an average-sized human
so really playing with the timing like
how quick she could move which was
really funny
early on the art departments working
more with story and directing with a
director to craft and figure out what
these toys are you know we're doing a
lot of research we're going to antique
stores we're going to carnivals we
rented an RV and had meetings and hung
out in the RV it was fun
so that research is a big part of the
early part of our process through the
process we're finding the film we don't
always exactly know how it's going to
end up but through the process of making
it we kind of discover I think a lot of
people don't know how chaotic behind
this thing and the making films can be
messy but at the same time very exciting
in pre-production we're really
concentrating on model testing the
models and making sure that they you
know can move freely without what we
call breaking which is you know that the
characters just don't look correct and
then we do a bunch of research we pull
tons of video reference of who we think
the characters are and really discover
the characteristic traits of each
character
[Music]
and then we sometimes pull clips from
movies or TV shows with that characters
voice for instance Annie Potts for book
PEEP and we'll animate a scene it's just
a test scene and we'll never be in any
movies but using that audio clip and
that's just testing to see what does she
look like when she's talking and moving
and jumping then after all this testing
is done and the characters ready to be
animated we apply her in shots in the
movie I know the perfect toy to help do
kaboom Canada's greatest stuntman oh
yeah yeah do you know one boy oh yeah
scale is really important to our love
because these characters are you know a
foot taller so all the textures and
materials and objects they interact with
are all tools to kind of help explain
the world that they're in the scale the
direct everything is down low everything
is up post and just imagine see on the
biggest beam possible I'm still seeing
things that I haven't yet noticed before
you'll notice an antique store there's a
lot of great dust and cobwebs and so
forth and those things we work really
hard at those because they deliver the
believability of the characters in that
world there's also so many Easter eggs
we've got in this movie within the
antique mall and I think if you see this
on an IMAX screen you're gonna have more
of a chance to see all of the things
from every Pixar film that's ever been
made that we've planted in the antique
store we made this film to be on the big
screen watching this an IMAX is just
probably just a visual treat much kibou
you
you